Paulie says we have a guest a guest a
surprise castle just a friend of the
show rendered the show long time long to
been on the show many time in time
here's the hint you love this guy with
the word love he's the most badass
catcher of all time
Johnny Bench Oh JP how are you I'm fine
I mean think 10 years back when he had
all those bugs in your attic and you
were producing and it was the only story
you had to cover at the time I'm coming
to you live from downtown Charlotte at
the Touchdown Club the Bronco burger
escape
touchdown club they've never had a male
baseball speaker here and I've got a boy
I've got to go in there and now I can
tell them I just talked to Dan Pat well
on his 10th year anniversary Wow
congratulations thank you the great
Johnny Bench former Cincinnati Red Cat
shirt of course hall-of-famer and you
know he's the one that everybody is
compared to when you're trying to
compare a catcher to a catcher you're
compared to Johnny Bench and if you are
that means you're one of the old-time
great so uh are you interested in the
baseball playoffs here what give me the
storyline that you are really interested
in Johnny I'm really watching Cleveland
I I was with amazement the number of
rolled what 22 wins they rolled off and
and the pitching staff I mean you almost
want to come back and catch when you got
passed like that I mean it's just you
can be Monet I mean you can paint
masterpieces I mean these guys it's
incredible to think what they've done
and you know they're going to get
overlooked a lot you know it says Lindor
and Ramirez and all the guys and and the
MVP numbers you know and I probably are
in that market that they don't get
noticed and you just the excitement of
being able to put those two together the
judge story the Sanchez all the things
that go with it I mean it's really an
exciting time and to see the Dodgers and
Belanger and to see Cole Schmidt and and
what Mark JD Martinez is done in the
Arizona and the lamb kid who put up
another 100 RBIs for them as well it's
got so many great stories I look for a
lot of all offense we've got it so far
in these first two playoff games so it's
just it's just a lot of fun I mean this
is a fun time of year for me if I said
you could catch one pitcher right now
one inning who do you want to catch
oh yeah I probably liked the competitor
that he is I'd probably catch Kershaw
what about chaff did you catch anybody
who threw that hard as Rolly Chapman no
I mean you know you get 100 miles an
hour but it's pretty straight so it's
not really a problem Wayne Simpson threw
95 miles an hour but he would grip it in
ways I don't know I think I swear I
threw the ball back to him it landed in
his love and I Everett landed he just
gripped it everything
Danny we're gonna sink it would slide it
would sail it was done and it was like
my hand was twice the size of its normal
size after catching him because he would
run that sinker and it would just take
off and there wasn't anything way to
stop it from eating your hand up on that
pad on your left on your palm and it
would just swell up so bad but you know
95 miles an hour with movement is a lot
better than 101 with no movement we saw
a moment with the Yankees the other
night Gary Sanchez got hit in the groin
and we wondered if everybody wears a cub
like catchers is it almost mandatory
that you have to wear protective Cup
well I broke seven of them so I really
had to get different ones I had to buy
new ones yeah I think it's mandatory to
get a new one I mean that's the only
thing I hope how did he crack well
velocity velocity you know it's coming
that my mother hard-plastic ever plastic
I never liked the metal because it just
felt like there wasn't enough stuff
around it I don't know why I didn't like
myself when he got hit I guess was the
thing it's kind of like having a driver
you know you had a driver and he was
paying and you don't like those but
palpable yeah I mean it had one crack in
seven places it was it was a three week
or DLF to that so how do you stay in the
game gotta be tough well nobody will
come out I mean you know in the old days
when I you know a outfielder run into a
wall I catch it in our trainer and run
out to the wall 200 feet away you know
in feeler head picture take one off the
shin and they'll run out pick him up I
catch her I'll take one dead in the cup
rising on the ground and the manager
the trainers are so let's go get a cup
of coffee okay we'll be fine
you can't take him out of the game you
got to have him he's needed because I
asked to work is it Sparky
I caught 54 days in a row without a day
off and I swear he said I'm not gonna
get a day off he's let me put it to you
this way if we're behind him what catch
you two catch up
if we're tired I'm gonna catch you to
get a hit if we're hit amongst a hit I'm
not getting a day off in less work he's
not really no it's great too great to
talk to you guys got your top ten yet oh
good yeah we didn't prepare for this
Johnny we know it was coming
no I didn't it kind of snuck up on me
I'm gonna be ready for the 20th
anniversary Johnny okay alright well
we'll be waiting for it because we'll be
listening to you for what you do for the
game of the sports of what you do it you
bring some real sensibility to it and
some honesty to it and you're not the
assassin that a lot of guys are so thank
you and congratulations on ten years
Thank You bud that's so the great Johnny
Bench they're calling it that's nice
good good stuff yeah Johnny Bench no no
love Johnny Bench the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience